your demented homophobic and transphobic
rhetoric and rants just further prove
our point that we have to fight loudly
to be respected the reason that lgbtqia
plus rates are so high in this country
it's because there are people like you
who make us feel like we don't belong is
is there a question in there or a speech
you got to ask a question buddy how do
you and how do you think other people
with your beliefs respond to the fact
that your hateful har rhetoric cost the
lives of we children every single day on
average every 45 seconds you're
pretending that someone committed
because of Candace Owens you've got no
facts here I sat down with a man named
wal High who was convinced to chop his
penis off after your community told him
that there was something wrong with him
because he had confusion and he
eventually chopped off his penis rates
go up after they transition after they
transition and Candace Owens wasn't the
one that chopped their disc off a lot of
people within this community just want
to scream at what they think the problem
is instead of actually looking at data
and statistics and coming to a logical
conclusion for what's actually going on